[Music]
sup
what's up big week for news guys
slow news day yesterday yeah
no doubt well we do have to send out a
few thoughts and prayers probably before
we get started
um some of the biggest stories of the
week
kim and kanye you know you hate to see
what happened oh
i was waiting for that one wait a minute
they're breaking up don't worry kim and
kanye will work it out
is that is that a real story it's true
really
i mean i think it's alleged true but
it's i didn't
i didn't make it up this time it went
shopping
um thoughts and prayers also go out to
uh jeff bezos
sad news for him yeah no longer the
richest man in the world
really who took them over elon musk
elon which is strange because i'm pretty
sure like none of elon's musk's
companies have made like any money
like i think it's all hypothetical yeah
isn't the spacex is probably generating
some
pretty lucrative speculations i think it
was actually
the tesla stock went up seven hundred
percent
in a year or so really
despite having basically no difference
to the products of other automakers as
far as i
can tell having released all the
blueprints to like all their vehicles is
like open source on the
internet too well not on the internet
but
to those who know where to find them i
think they're barely profitable
now well we're still all looking for the
electric revolution but it just seems
like the regular car manufacturers
are stepping in for that but greg yay
elon good
good job you're well done capitalism
yeah
but of course the biggest event of the
week the one that
everyone's talking about politics is in
absolute turmoil
um i don't i don't know if i believe it
and i don't know if anyone else is going
to believe what's happening
up here but it's in all the newspapers
uh the electorate is livid of course
so here's what happened i'll read it
i'll read a summary yeah
rarely is a public outcry rooted in so
many offensive elements
which are so easy to understand yet so
difficult to comprehend
there's the hypocrisy of politicians
pledging
solidarity with those in lonely
isolation even
as they searched online to upgrade seats
for family reunions
there's the raw deception of mps mlas
and a senator
pretending to be among us in
pre-recorded christmas greetings
when they knew they'd be slathering on
sunscreen at the swim up bar
by the time it was released my god
should you believe this how dare they go
on vacation
can you seriously imagine so we are of
course talking about
the uh disgusting cancerous
canadian politicians who left to go on
vacation
while they were supposed to be isolating
in covet i feel like this is a
fascist coup of my health and well-being
yeah they're kicking back in hawaii and
other colonial holdings well i'm stuck
here what kind of [ __ ] blows my mind
about it is they had to know that
somebody was going to figure this out
eventually and that it was going to look
really really bad like it's hard to hide
those kind of things at this point and
apparently some of them even had
pictures in them
floating around online on vacation
i'm like what did you not think that
maybe it'd be better not to [ __ ] like
jump into that shot hello you are on the
pill pod and we are
canadian proudly canadian uh that's tbd
we know america's on fire and we're
gonna get there but the big news in
canada this week
is that politicians pre-recorded
messages encouraging
citizens the electorate to stay home
for christmas while they went to uh
cancun
and some of them are still hiding down
there some of them are hiding together
like mexico and stuff they're hiding
wait did something happen in the states
oh you didn't didn't you see the fire i
don't i don't actually pay attention
you know caught fire the kanye news or
the
other news i have a south-facing window
so i can see there's a little bit of
smoke
rising he said america was on fire what
do you mean it's on fire
go stand on your back porch well canada
canada got the smoke from california
maybe that's it
there's a little bit of forest fire
fumes coming up our way
it's nice though i didn't have to smoke
as much weed while that was happening
[Laughter]
sorry that's not who we are i don't
represent everybody on this pod
i don't think anyone represents anyone
on this pod and we may disagree on the
significance of this
event deep but there shall be no there
shall be no coups of the podcast
or a cruise of my of my health and
well-being coup de tate
anyway what uh hey i get it
what a perfect end to trumpism we can
call it an end
i don't think there's anyone to don the
mantle of the gaping hole he's going to
leave in
the politics of our neighbors to the
south i guess that does depend on where
he spends his twilight years
mar-a-lago i'm excited for the new
disciplines this is going to open up in
this year
trumpology trumponomy trumpenometrics
coupism
trump studies yeah polyside departments
are going to be
rolling in it it's going to be a new
subfield in my political
science department it'll be the sixth
one uh yeah trump studies
trump studies how to perform a
trumpectomy i was thinking about all the
poor video game designers and
show runners who are going to have to
come up with plots as stupid as this
for their they should be this should be
the plot of assassin's creed not like
not the napoleon's coup but the cow
shaman cou yeah i remember the
south park creators were just so they're
not even gonna do anything on trump
because he just like deconstructs
himself
i'm actually wondering who's gonna play
him in a biopic 10 years from now
because you know perfectly well like
the oliver stone of
the next decade or something is going to
see this is pers a perfect oscar bait
and i was like well they were able to
pull w off
and then they were able to also pull um
[ __ ] like barack obama off
but who can they possibly get to play
trump yeah you know what you should
actually see there's a
mini series a two-part mini-series
called the comey rule trump is played
by um brendan gleason yes i remember you
telling me about that
yeah i could see that one work is
actually quite good it's it's
impressively good because i think
pulling off a trump
you have to really toe the line and and
somehow like avoid
being a caricature when trump himself is
a caricature so it's like how do you
play somebody
without it just seeming like like the
alec baldwin like hilarious
yeah that's what i was thinking about it
it's gonna be really difficult to step
out of baldwin's
shadow since he gave such a definitive
take on the character
i'll send you a video actually of
gleason doing it it's pretty impressive
he gets
um he gets this the head tilt and the
breaths
really well like i don't know if you
ever if you guys ever noticed how trump
has this weird way of breathing where
he'll kind of be like
it's disgraceful and he'll like breathe
in as he's talking and tilt his head i
don't know if you guys
there's like there's a very distinct
breathing pattern that trump has that
this this actor captures
very well it's that mcnugget sauce
that's just blocking up his airways
maybe we can find like a cousin or
something to play them maybe like back
when
larry david did bernie sanders that was
pretty on point
yeah we'll need somebody like that i
think i think shy the beef is going that
direction if he
if he just carries on for another 10
years he'll look like trump
it'll be trumpish just get kanye to play
him you know that can be his oscar
winner
his oscar roll yeah hopefully that's
within his range
all right i don't know where we all are
on this event i think we'd
probably disagree well can i just say i
i loved um
to some extent i i liked it um not like
because i was happy that it like
that it happened but i was but in the
sense that
i think a lot of these um like trump you
know stop the steal
um their their kind of whole motivation
was
was somehow sustained by a fantasy of
um oh like we're gonna do this we're
gonna overcome all this
and i think there's something kind of
satisfying about watching them like
storm it it's like what are you gonna do
and then
they storm it and then it's like nothing
happens and if anything it had like
a very damaging effect it was kind of
like a splash of cold water
oh contraire though they got in there
do now they got in there and their
purpose
evidently was to take selfies of
themselves having got in there
sure okay no no but hold on hold on so i
think like
there's the point that shijak makes a
lot about like um
the the sort of role that um lost causes
has in our fantasy like if we never get
to attempt something it's like it stays
alive
more so to some extent i think that like
the fact that
they went they got into the capital and
nothing happens it kind of interrupts
the ability for for that fantasies to be
sustained where they can be like
well if only we would have tried you
know we could have done something and
it's like well
you got into the capital and like splash
cold water on like your little
like jewish sons of of of of um
i don't know imagine what what could
have been possible he references yeah
lacan and this notion of the two deaths
as a kind of metaphor for what happens
uh where he says if you look at various
political classes you know if you look
at various uh figures following higgle
throughout history people like napoleon
sometimes you're dead but you're not
really cognizant yet of the fact that
you're dead so of course napoleon was
utterly defeated you know in the war of
the sixth coalition but then he managed
to stage what he thought was a comeback
for 100 days
before you know it all ended
catastrophically with the battle of
waterloo and he was shipped to an even
crappier island where he died
and it does seem i agree with victor in
some senses like this follows the same
structure where
it was pretty clear that trumpism had
been dealt a mortal blow
when he lost the election especially
since so much of trump's brand is
associated with winning and overcoming
and
beating the odds uh but rather than
acknowledge that it kind of limped
onwards
and now there was this attempt at some
kind of revolutionary
outrage uh a revolutionary rupture to
restore him to power
uh but it all just ended up coming
across as extraordinarily banal
and kind of impotent and demonstrating
that no trumpism really is dead
right if anything it's not dead as a
movement but as an administration and as
a government
at least for now yeah what was that
quote lenin attributes
lenin attributes to uh napoleon you
might not have said it but it was
something like jump into the fray and
then decide what to do
i think that's what we saw yesterday
yeah
that is the sixth except the napoleon's
plural we're pretty good at coos
they have what they have three
successful coups between
them yeah i mean this wasn't a coup
obviously well but i mean
this actually demonstrates why it is
that trump is really not a particularly
skilled
political actor and a lot of people have
pointed this out i think corey robin is
the most successful of them right but
you know he's postured as a political
genius because he kind of beat the odds
and won the 2016 election
and before that run the republican
nomination uh but it's worth noting that
he did so
uh under very circumscribed conditions
uh by very narrow margins
and since then he's remained
tremendously unpopular he wasn't able to
expand his base
despite the fact that the republicans
had all three branches of government he
wasn't even able to push through
any major piece of legislation and then
he lost the second election and it looks
like he lost pretty much
every elected branch of government
that's available to the republicans
but isn't this tragic for the followers
these pig men
one of whom got shot for him and they
don't
want anything they just want him or
their image of him to look down shining
upon them
and he's the one who says we're going
down to the capitol
i'll be with you and then he just sits
and watches them on tv
while they're hood and hollering doughy
hog brain that's what he wanted yeah
that's what he wanted he's it was all
narcissistic he just wanted like like
that's why he had such a hard time
condemning them
because the fact that he knew all of
those people in the capital were there
because they [ __ ] love him so much
that is irresistible to him so he
couldn't help himself
he couldn't help himself and and condemn
them because he's like how in his mind
he's like
how could i condemn people who love me
this much it's like that's all he wants
right
all his main op operandi is
like getting people to love him uh yeah
he doesn't
care about politics really and this is
what i was getting at like successful
coups throughout history
uh and you get the guy like the
bolshevik revolution uh
against you know the february government
uh in 1917 and then
brothers take a lot of work and they
also require intense focus on detail
because
really you have to be able to pull off
what's the equivalent of a political
magic trick
where you swap out the one government
and then replace it so quickly that it's
almost like nobody really knows what
happened
and by the time your enemies kind of
realize what's going on uh you've
already kind of trained the status quo
uh trump didn't do anything that was
necessary to actually kind of
solidify that kind of possibility by for
instance reaching out to the military
uh or the police to try to make sure
that they would give him a carp launch
to do whatever he wanted
uh all he's doing exactly
he didn't have any kind of institutional
allies exactly right uh in any of the
major administration of the us
government
all that he really had as victor pointed
out uh was this mob of people who loved
him
and it's not surprising that he didn't
really think to expand beyond that since
that's pretty much who he is right he's
i'm that's a narcissistic feeds off of
his base and their reverence for him all
the other stuff
uh takes too much work and involves
actually making the kind of
oddly enough uh you know the deals uh
that he defined himself on for a little
while
uh but would actually which actually
make up so much of political life in
which she's proven really incompetent
right failing grade on the
insurrectionary report card
and the first president in who wasn't
who hasn't been assassinated that only
served one term
i don't think there's
in the 80 and he only served one term
and he got beat by reagan which is a
shame because i actually like carter
quite a bit but
uh anyway we got four deaths one was
gunshot related
three were fast food related allegedly
the other death the three deaths i think
one guy tasered himself
at least that was that might have been a
twitter jig
we'll just say three of them were fast
food related but at least they all died
happy serving their god emperor
the god emperor of their facebook this
was a live facebook event it
was it was respect i agree it was a
spectacle too you know but i think the
story to me isn't so much that this was
a coup i mean obviously it wasn't aku it
had none of the institutional markings
of a coup
it was more a story of the the sort of
psychological impact
that that's conspiracy theories can have
on people that like alternative media
that like youtubers
and having a president stoke those
flames and and create like fear
uncertainty and
doubt in people that that matches their
own predisposed
political biases their love for trump
you know you put all those things
together with like the modern media
landscape
and this spectacle is uh what you get
from it
yeah and that's why i actually take this
more significantly
they're thinking of my pills uh and it's
because even trump himself is pretty
incompetent
right and i think we're both pointing
this out uh he need to possess the kind
of tactical acumen
uh or really the patience to pull off
something that would genuinely resemble
a coup
right all he was able to do was rile up
his base kind of stick them on his
political opponents
and then it all broke uh like waves on a
rock right
uh but it doesn't mean that somebody
can't embody a kind of trumpist
postmodern approach to politics
uh and do so a lot more effectively and
with much more tactical acumen
and political sensibilities than donald
trump
right uh and i think actually what we
saw just before this happened
uh was a couple of heirs apparent trying
to do just that somebody like ted cruz
right uh who is genuinely a pretty smart
guy seemed kind of desperate to
seize the trumpet mantle for himself by
continuing to propagate these false
stories that the election had been
stolen
uh arguing that by dp pence should
disqualify certain electors
all that kind of stuff right so that's
what really worries me about the future
especially given trump's age and the
unlikelihood of him
having a political capital to run again
in i guess 2024. all right well i'll
introduce some
points for debate at least uh hang on
there's one
there's one last detail that nobody's
talking about there are explosive
devices found
at both the rnc and the dnc headquarters
which were which were successfully
safely detonated
but i mean nobody's talking about that
[ __ ]
that seems pretty significant to me talk
about it eric
well well i'm talking about the lack of
coverage
right i mean it's true that that wasn't
like covered but i mean
i guess does that would that add more to
the argument that this was a coup
attempt or or
or just like more mischief more i mean
the people
literally like most of these people
literally thought that this election was
stolen like
like most of them actually believe that
in their heart of hearts and that's
danger a dangerous combination of
beliefs like with the whole media
landscape
and uh you know i i want to make a
prediction right now that i hope doesn't
come true but but i think
will is i think that during biden's
presidency you're going to see a
domestic terrorist attack similar to
the oklahoma city bombing yeah and
that's what worries me
about the future also like i was saying
before uh
i think that the kind of comparisons to
the beer help pooch uh
are actually really overstated because
that was actually carried off with a lot
more success uh at least for a little
while
than what we saw here in part because
the nazis did actually try to coordinate
with major sectors of german society
and try to get the military on their
side and were actually able to seize
control of munich for a brief period of
time
etc etc etc but you know later on they
did actually seize power legitimately
because the energy of their movement
wasn't really dissipated
uh it was actually vitalized uh by the
fact that they almost successfully
pulled this off
at least for a few days um and then you
know the german authorities went soft on
them because a lot of people were
nationalists and sympathized with what
they were trying to do right
uh what worries me is that this might be
the end of trump
and his administration and i think
there's no question it will be since
he's losing a lot of political allies
but i'm not sure this will be the end of
trumpism or post-modern conservatism or
neo-fascism or traditionalism
you know whatever you want to call it
right i think that it might actually
have a long future ahead of it and
i really worry about what what will
happen if somebody a lot more competent
and a lot more ruthless uh gets
seizes the mantle uh of this kind of
outlook well
my point number one was media
fear-mongering and now you're doing it
for us so
we have uh both sides represented that
is concerning though
it's concerning for you yeah i'm not i'm
not concerned
at all but i wanted to at least
introduce a point that we can debate
which is 100 to me this is a pseudo
event a pseudo event
is images taken out of the
consequence versus uh cause
we would see a normal political action
in history
so i'm taking the side that this is a an
image
that will have probably no consequences
i'll defend that
um and the the image is the perfect
image to me is this cow
the cowhead guy sitting at the chair at
the head
of the legislature and should we not
expect
that the head of the legislature was
always a person wearing a cow head
anyway um so yeah the first
the blue check twitter is freaking out
calling them terrorists
calling them nazis making the
comparisons with the beer hall pooch
very funny to me um and to me that shows
a
lack of imagination that journalists
have because the only
anytime they see a threat to democracy
it's a nazi comparison
immediately current affairs did it the
one that you just mentioned
and yeah i i i would hope that we can
have a better
sense of imagination particularly
because of what we said a few weeks ago
there's no one committed enough to be a
fascist
and the people that are committed enough
to be fascists have almost no effect on
american politics where all of the power
is still exactly where the power was
before this all happened which is why i
say that it's completely inconsequential
it's it's the parties and the donors
not the cow guy that is the enemy um
well i think that's i guess you know to
to to just say well this is just an
image this is just a spectacle i mean i
guess
i think that those things can have a
huge influence on people's
minds and i think yesterday we saw um
you know a proof of that i think because
i do think that that these people were
motivated by spectacle
by by like these these ridiculous images
of things
of of you know the of ideas i guess
maybe the in that case they're not
images or like the belief in that the
election was stolen but
in any case like i don't think it's it's
uh inconsequential like i certainly
wouldn't write it off but i agree that
the media
is very quick and hasty because they
don't understand
uh the alternative uh media like
landscape they don't understand youtube
very well so i think when they see
something like this happen
um they do jump to these you know pretty
pretty like
simplistic takes and and they they get
very um
uh alarmist i suppose so i don't i don't
i don't disagree that the media's
reaction to it but but i also agree with
matt that that this
that that um this is in p
these this spectacle is having is going
to have an impact on people
um i'm already seeing like uh a lot of
these kind of more white nationalist or
not white nationalists but
traditionalist far right you know
trumper people
on twitter talking about how they want
to burn the republican party down
and they're celebrating and after
they're seeing like lindsey graham and
all these people quickly turn their
backs
and by the way as an aside jesus lindsey
graham i don't know if any of you guys
saw his speech but
yeah holy [ __ ] did he like i do a 180
quickly like yeah
like after after he won his senate seat
narrowly in south carolina
he was like i'm gonna fight with you to
the end trump and then other and then as
soon and then on the
floor of the senate like yesterday or
this morning or something i saw him in
almost like restrained jubilation
so happy to be like totally turning us
back and being like yeah we're not going
to do this like we were never going to
do this
it's like what the [ __ ] like holy [ __ ]
this guy is
like [ __ ] a rat escaping a sinking
ship
as quickly as possible instantly like i
i don't agree with what you're saying
but i'll defend to the death you're
right to say it
that's their that's their sort of
fallback position but also stoked the
fears of a stolen election for so long
and then now it's like it's like he
it's like he didn't he never did it he's
like totally did a 180.
yeah but i do think this speaks sorry
this speaks to
i just want to respond directly to that
because when i say consequential
it definitely has to do with
institutional
power and decisions that are made by
legislative bodies
that actually affect individuals and on
that ground
i think that trumpism is less effective
today
than it was two days ago because now
the whole institution is saying no we
have a firewall
i'm not saying that some psycho is not
going to blow up a building in the
future
but that's always a threat right that
that threat might be marginally
increased
or not i think it's more even an event
like that yeah i'm going to split the
difference even even a threat like that
though is not different from three days
ago
but or under the ins the institutions
have very much
drawn a firewall saying we are not that
we condemn that even the ones that were
flirting with it like you just said
a few days ago now like that is that is
definitely fringe it's been pushed to
the fridge yeah i'm gonna split the
difference between these two and say
that i think there are two reasons why
we need to be more concerned
than pills is allowing uh while still
acknowledging that i think
uh everyone's right that trumpism is
certainly less effective now
than it was even yesterday in part
because of this event and in this sense
it's
less something to catastrophize and more
something to
recognize as i would think almost the
death throes of at least this
administration
and the two things that i wanted to
point out which are reasons for concern
is that
this doesn't really represent a dramatic
shift
in the way that the gop is actually
approach politics
i would actually say that the dear man
that you saw on the senate floor
is actually the way gop politics have
been moving for a very long time
at least since the 1980s and you could
talk about the emergence of people like
rush limbaugh
you can talk about newt gingrich and his
hyper partisanship and the contract with
america
you can talk about the attempt to
essentially impeach like clinton over
the blow job
alex jones and the infowars alex jones
where they get it all from
yeah the bush administration talking
about how it is that we create our own
reality now
and then all the kind of postmodern
politics that you see associated with
trumpism right and it's unreality it's
fake news uh it's highly identitarian
orientation breitbart you name it right
uh and none of that is going to go away
uh just because
this event uh if you want to call it
that is de-legitimated
yeah this is a full-blown subculture
we're dealing with
exactly and in our hyper-connected
digital world now these people
find each other it's just like it
reminds me of the flat earthers right
like those
those people who they have their own
conferences they have their own events
people meet their freaking
wives and husbands at these things and
like it's a it's a community it's a
whole subculture and and
you guys actually just have something
like that out there's an opinion poll
45 of republicans uh thought that
storming the capital was justified and a
good idea
yeah and this is what i'm saying like
certainly this has been a slap in the
wrist
not a slap in the rest it's a pretty big
condemnation uh of trumpism that even
senior members of the gop who were
allies uh of trump
are now turning against him uh but
whether or not that's actually going to
shift
the direction of american conservatism i
think is a much more open question
uh and the second thing is that i agree
with you that there's this kind of
spectral quality to what went on
uh in the sense that materially and
institutionally it's not shifted all
that much
but what i think that you know following
bojar what you really see is
precisely that that what we're seeing in
the 21st century is
the subordination of the reality
principle uh
to hyper reality right where the image
of politics
has now become what politics is and it's
not connected to anything that's more
substantial than that and
trump is flourished in this kind of
environment uh and even if he himself
goes or is canceled
uh or people tire of his particular
stick somebody else might very well come
along
and be able to embody the same qualities
maybe even somebody who's younger and
more competent with
the kind of media and subcultures uh
that a lot of john jr
yeah don jr right or someone uh and so
that's what concerns me because i do
think that this is an apocalypse shift
uh or cultural shift if you want that
we're not going to get away from uh
which also contributes to exacerbating a
lot of the tendencies that we've seen in
american conservatism for a long time
since i think it thrives precisely in
this kind of hyper real highly
narrativized environment
oh and also i should say just uh as a
comment on eric this was a funny thing
um i saw this website the other day
where
uh conservatives now don't want to live
near liberals so you can
they actually are creating uh websites
online where
you can try to buy a house in a
conservative neighborhood and the aim is
to essentially
funnel you into what are really safe
spaces by any other name
right uh while you'll be in the same
neighborhood with other people and i was
watching an interview with the guy who
was
organizing this website and he said like
look i just think that make good fences
make good neighbors uh and not having
any liberals around tends to make me
happy so
you know wow yeah i mean this has really
become a mode of life
you know conservative ethno state um
i see your beaudry art and i raise you
deborah
who said something like a democracy
loves to have an incomprehensible enemy
like terrorism i don't know maybe kovid
agamben would
now there's this uh latent fear
that is propagated and the latent fear
is for
whatever this is trump trumpism i don't
know what it's going to be called after
that
but then the institution can allow
everyone to convince themselves that
compared to terrorism
what you have is really good so nothing
will be changed so we talked about
agambin once on this podcast way back
who said that
kovid was going to be a state of
exception i think we all
disagreed and dismissed that but if
there's a fear that i would have out of
this
and fear monger i would fear monger that
this state of exception is going to be
used to the full extent that it can be
to justify any manner of
of state interventions and
and that kind of uh repression of
otherwise or
freedoms that we would have had now yeah
and i would say that that's actually the
wrong way to approach this
and uh one of the reasons is that
trumpism has thrived uh in an atmosphere
where people feel that their political
institutions are de-legitimated because
they only serve
elite interests uh and i don't think
that's just true with trump you also saw
similar
uh animosities provoking things like
brexit or the turn to law and justice in
poland you know you name it and
what i think we need right now is a
process of democratic renewal
uh to allow people to feel that their
institutions reflect their actual wishes
rather than doubling down
on elite driven technocracy in the name
of security or whatever it happens to be
so that's what i take away from kevin
but
i mean i do also think that right now
there's a there's a real opportunity i
mean the democrats also
like one which i think is forgotten they
won both senate seats so now the
democrats have control of all
branches of government um and i do think
that there's probably
um real motivation to to pass things
like health care
um and the two thousand dollar stimulus
and all these other things which
um which is it i mean i think one of the
things that's interesting
with the mega crowd the mega cult
is that there is an underlying um
economically left-wing populist element
to it
which is kind of interesting like and
trump was pushing right the two thousand
dollars
um so i guess so i wonder whether or not
there's an opportunity here for
for the the democrats to to pass some
things that will make
um that mega like like economically
left-wing uh
populist aspect like happy or i don't
know pacify them a little bit by giving
them health care giving them two
thousand dollars they don't want to
they already won like now that the now
that the fascists
quote unquote tried to take over the set
the the legislatures
they don't have to do anything for four
years which is what that deboer
quote that i mentioned is kind of saying
they don't have to do anything anymore
because they
can say at least we're not that well i
actually disagree like i do think that
there's a momentum in the democratic
party to to pass those things
those i'll say i hope that history
proves me wrong i'll say a complicated a
more more complication here though
because what what pilly boy is saying is
is uh on track i think
is that well i hope that doesn't stick
and remember
that magga and this wave of
far-right people like trump did not
cause this
right this is something that cornell
west brings up is that this
movement of the far right began under
obama
it began under the democrats not so the
democrats are
just as much to blame for this whole
situation as the republicans
and that's why the fact that trump is
going down in flames really
doesn't give me any [ __ ] comfort
whatsoever because now we have
mr joe biden the [ __ ] king of the
milk toast presidents coming into office
and
like what's he gonna do he's just gonna
resume a kind of obama program where
it's like all right
let's switch republican donors out for
big corporate democrat donors and
nothing's going to be any different and
the same
social issues that cause this sort of
unrest
are just going to exacerbate further
unless there is a real
actual change in the democratic party a
good
sign of which would be for them to
accept something like a green
new deal or some other more radical
kind of platform like that rather than
just moving back
to like this sort of safe democratic
politics because that
everyone said that's the problem in the
first place conservatives and democrats
they're all
liberals they're just a little bit
different side of the same [ __ ]
spectrum
they're all the same in the end and
we're just switching out one
for another the puppet on the left and
the puppet on the right and
basically the same person holds both
puppets and it's all
like that's why this to some extent i
mean i think the idea that
trump is sort of this is a big turning
point no it's not
give me a [ __ ] break i mean i think
you're right that um
that that i don't think there's um
gonna be like some bit radical shifts
you need something
i mean you need to change the entire
system of government in the states i
mean the
so the i agree to some extent i do think
that we're going to see these
what are pretty moderate things like the
things i mentioned are not revolutionary
right just like get having a public
option like the 2 000
stimulus like a couple other things like
that's not right
other countries at all
oh yeah exactly a lot of other countries
have gotten a lot more but i don't think
the reason for that alone is
because of um part of the reason for
that though is also the institutional
factor like even though the the
democrats won the senate
um they don't have a super like they
need um 60 votes
to pass uh a filibuster so even now
um you know that it's not possible like
i think a lot of lefties are going to
start getting mad at biden for not doing
more
but even if he wanted to do more even if
he wanted to do literally everything
that bernie wanted to do
there are a bunch of institutional and
also party factors
one being joe manchin who's like a
moderate democrat who is already on
record
saying he will not support a great new
deal he will not support right so like
there's just so many factors in play
that you can't just blame by
him for i'm sure biden's happy about it
but i'm just saying there's like a bunch
of other factors that
are structural and procedural even like
like factors that would exist if bernie
sanders was president right now in the
same conditions
the same barriers would exist and he
would have just as much
chance of passing the things that he
wanted yeah well the bill to abolish the
filibuster
in the great cosmic irony would probably
get filibustered
yeah well i know this is one of the
problems right and i think victor is
exactly right
and people have talked about how it is
that um
during the 1930s uh through the 1950s
because there was a kind of overlapping
consensus around a kind of
moderate social welfarism and the two
parties were less polarized on many
issues
it was actually possible to pursue a
pretty ambitious legislative agenda
and you saw people like uh fdr do that
you saw people
like um excuse me um you know lydia
johnson did that
even saw people like reagan do that up
through the but it's because the two
party of the
parties have become extremely polarized
it's very very difficult to get anyone
to shift
on their positions and i think that this
might not be a problem in a purely
majoritarian legislative setting
where all you need is 50 plus one but
the problem is that the united states
is designed uh so the american
constitution is designed to be
extremely resistant to change uh and
extremely resistant to any ambitious
legislative efforts
unless there's broad bipartisan consent
uh to them and
for that reason you've seen legislative
gridlock on virtually any kind of
substantive measures
for the past what is it 30 years now or
so
i mean if you look at the legislative
achievements of somebody like clinton
they're pretty minimal
bush actually wasn't enabled really to
do all that much except enact a bunch of
tax cuts
uh you know at the domestic level i mean
it did cause the asian market collapse
but
no no i set that aside i talked about
domestic legislation
okay well this is one of the things one
of the few powers that really is quite
substantial
is the executive power over foreign
affairs that's vested in the office of
the president right
yeah but if you look at obama his
signature achievement right the
affordable care act
that only came after he won a massive
sweeping victory
in all the elected branches of
government uh
and really had to struggle to push
through
uh the affordable care act which was
only the result of just
hamstringing compromises uh with
the moderate democrats and gop members
who might be willing to sign on to some
provisions
and then trump's the only legislative
accomplishment again more tax cuts
right and i think people are really sick
of this and really tired of it but it's
very difficult for the reasons that
victor was pointing out and a lot of
others to see how that could
fundamentally change
without big institutional changes that's
why i always get frustrated with like
with
i get frustrated with like the online
left or you know the bernie or bust
because
i'm always like okay like that's
premised on your your own
misunderstanding of how the american
political system works it doesn't really
matter if bernie was president or not
like
like so many i think it would matter he
would make a
a difference to the extent possible
right and it would push him more left
agenda
i mean he would make a rhetorical
difference but he wouldn't make a
difference in the senate he wouldn't
make a difference in the house of
representatives
it would just be like symbolic but then
he wouldn't be able to get anything done
like you would need the house and the
senate to be democratic socialists
like that like that's what so you would
literally need everybody to be i don't
know why you're saying that these
parties are polarized either
that's exactly the opposite of what eric
just said he said they're both serving
the same interest which is 100 what i
agree with
yeah but so and what you're saying that
they just don't do anything
that's the success of the system it's
designed not to do anything
except for the donors that are the same
for both parties whether or not you give
tax cuts
yeah they're culturally polarized by
partisanship i mean this is the thing if
you look at the way that conservatives
speak about
back up through the 1980s uh people were
willing to sometimes
agree uh that the other side the other
political party
had something of value to offer right
but this is rhetorical
this is not it is
fundamentally shift any change of wealth
any distribution of wealth except who
has it
and it goes up all the time well no i i
actually think that that misapprehends
how it is that the us political system
works right
uh there is real polarization in the
united states between people like
democratic socialists
who really do want to pursue a radical
agenda uh and
things like uh social conservative
capitalists who want exactly the
opposite
the reason no democratic socialist
agenda has ever been advanced
like since at least what the the okay
but this is what i'm getting at right
the reason the reason why it is that you
see very little
cause very little difference in how the
actual parties
engage in governance isn't because
there's no real polarization in the
populations because there's dramatic
polarization
in the population which means that the
two parties tend to pursue
what's sometimes called the median voter
right the most average person right in
the middle
uh who's not going to have any views
that are going to offend anyone
because you're fighting for very thin
margins uh when it comes to any election
right so it's actually a consequence of
the partisanship that you see in the
united states
sorry like in american culture that
there's so little difference in the
actual policies the party pursues
uh because none of the parties are
actually willing to pursue a radical
agenda that will upset
the few people in the middle who might
be willing to shift their opinion
right so there's a problem with the
representation of a representative
democracy but that's exactly the same
thing as i'm saying the system's working
like it should
for the people that are paying for it i
think i agree that it's the same thing
to say that they're completely different
as to say that they're the same and
there is no
difference when you draw a really hard
line around politics and you don't look
at the extra political factors that
influence this
like sure things didn't change since the
70s except the internet
social media econ world economic
relations like
everything other than politics has
basically changed
and now we're looking at drawing a
circle around politics and looking at
politics to figure out
what the hell is happening and nobody's
looking outside nobody's looking at say
what's the wrong well people are looking
at this what's the role in facebook
in destabilizing this what's the role in
new geopolitical configurations that
have emerged in the past decade or two
and their influence on american politics
like american politics is not happening
in a vacuum
but so your assessment is great in so
far as it is
siloed in a purely political economic
view of the states but when you start
factoring in all these that's exactly
the opposite what i said though i said
wealth
distribution is the only thing that's
changed about politics
well wealth distribution has like you
know it improved after world war
ii it was more distributed and then
since i said since the 70s
so yeah well we moved up just stretching
back a bit further than since the
neoliberal
revolutions in the 70s and 80s the
wealth gap has slowly gotten worse again
okay that's a huge
factor in all of this but some of the
other ways that we
do politics today and then we learn
about things you know you talk about
this as a spectacle
well what is the spectacle what is
carrying these images right
like in the old analog days we'd all be
reading about this
this morning in our with our with our
corn cob pipes and our rocking chairs
out on
our decks and then when the boy throws
the newspaper onto the balcony
but now we have this we have this
phenomena called instant explanation i
think it's something like benjamin's
was saying this back in the day an event
barely is even allowed to take place
before it is explained to death
and spun in a thousand different
directions and that's why we're never
going to get to the truth behind any of
this
everyone's going to be glued to their
streams and their
image sources and their media bubbles
and everyone's going to be looking at it
through these separate lenses
where what we need to do is maybe
broaden our scope a little bit and try
to look
outside politics and purely economic
causes
right or else we're just being
determinists about it yeah and this is
what i was going
this is kind of what i was trying to get
at right that in the kind of earlier era
of print media
uh that you saw existing uh through the
19 you know the late 19th century up
until about the mid
late 20th century right it was possible
for people to consume
relatively complex media that would
expose them to a wide variety of
alternate viewpoints
and for them to just view that as normal
and part of the community that they
lived in
right you could pick up a newspaper and
it would usually have a polemical point
uh but they would use you'd usually at
least get exposure to a few different
socialist views left-wing views
right-wing views et cetera et cetera
and what you've seen right now with
political stratification is people
entering into their silos
and hearing nothing really of substance
about the other side aside from the fact
that they're wrong about everything
and the interesting thing about this is
there really is deep political and
cultural disagreements
in the united states over virtually
everything right a democratic socialist
uh on the far left who wants trans
rights for all
uh weeds you know wheat and every other
drug completely legalized
and a vast welfare state and uh worker
ownership the means of production
has a very different outlook on what
society should look like than
a christian libertarian uh who thinks
that
you know guns jesus uh and
capital uh are what should make the
world go around right i guess where do
i guess what i want to ask then is where
would all this disagreement have come
from because when we
hear like i think you talk about bernie
sanders saying
that in the 60s you know a lot of bernie
sanders platforms were
like the general consensus platforms
whereas
today bernie sanders platform is
extremely divisive
and only appreciated by people on the
far left
or the or the real left and it's a
divisive
so where did this division come from and
yes like economic disparity is a huge
cause behind it but where else did it
come from you can't just sort of
use political division to explain
why there's political division that's
like a tautology
and if i may just attack on to that
point what you're calling politics
is what you're saying ordinary people
believe which is absolutely not what i'm
calling politics because what they
believe
has no recognizable effect on the way
that power shifts or that a country is
governed as evinced by the last
40 years well but this is what i'm
saying it does right and it's precisely
because the united states is so
polarized culturally
you know along the parameters that we've
discussed but that's why it's
working why is it polarized like eric
just said
the southern strategy that's why it's
political yeah but this is what i'm
trying to explain
right that because there's mass
polarization on the part of the
americans
of american society right uh you have
two political parties because the
institutions are designed to produce a
two-party system
right who have very little interest in
chasing after
what they consider to be fringe views
right
because they know perfectly well that
they have their supporters
and most of the people on the fringe are
going to align with them no matter what
right people bernie sanders supporters
are never going to break from the
democratic party
uh because the only alternative then is
something like donald trump right
this means that the kind of people that
both parties tend to pursue
are the median voters right the people
who exist
in the middle and who have very
innocuous views
and that tends to keep politics moving
on a relatively unambitious
straight and narrow course yeah maybe
that tells me a little bit that the uh
the the moderate voter's an abstraction
it doesn't really exist just like
obama's middle class it doesn't really
exist it's just an abstraction
and you don't really need to appeal to
them at all because it doesn't make a
difference because they're not [ __ ]
there because they're just a number and
apology well it's true so
so back to back up pills too like i
think what you were saying is
that what the average person thinks has
no impact and it's actually interesting
there's when i was studying uh
like comparative politics that it's like
the political science research on
american politics
has a very strong consensus all the
evidence shows pretty much that like
um a random citizen's policy preference
has almost no impact on what policies
are chosen
in fact like it's it there's the
relationship is almost is
i remember the quote was something like
in the abstract was something like
the relationship is so weak that it may
as well not exist yeah
like between um a voter between like
policy preference of the voter
and what policies are actually enacted
by the government and they have all
other reasons which are like
institutional reasons
like um private interests like special
interests
and like as much having a much stronger
relationship
i wonder what that scale is relative to
uh
corporate donors but that's exactly my
point you're saying nothing happens
because they're appealing to a middle
and i'm saying like you're just you're
over determining
the effect by not just saying money
dominates the system
money gets decisions made not voters
well i think that the two things are
fundamentally related right i mean what
you have
in most u.s elections is again a
two parties in which there are many
fringe views right competing for
a small minority of voters who might
change their mind in certain swing
states
right and so this requires unbelievable
amounts of money to try to target those
voters
and get them to shift one way or another
right but because what do you mean oh
explain that explain that
get them to shift well i mean if you
think about voters in florida you can
think about voters in ohio you can think
what is the specific mechanism by which
they get convinced vince them with
commercials and [ __ ]
well this is what i'm saying it's
usually by being targeted by
theirs that's what i was looking for
that's exactly but it's highly expensive
but
also it's it's also important it's also
important to disentangle paul
like a citizen's random policy
preference when you ask them like what
they want to happen
and their allegiance to a party too
because there's tons of people who
they're
citizens are totally inconsistent and
incoherent with their beliefs like
you ask them like do you want like
health care or whatever
and then depending on how you ask the
question they'll say yes or no like
that's why
brianna joy gray and like all these
other cringy leftist
they often say like oh like the the
public supports a green new deal
but like that's based on some survey but
like the way you ask the survey question
matters like if you say
are you willing to pay like you know 10
more a month in taxes to pay for the
green new deal
like the the support for it goes like
below 30 whereas if you ask like do you
support the green new deal
so like in any case the point is like
citizens are totally incoherent so
like people are often they have
allegiance to a party because it's their
team
but but that doesn't necessarily mean um
that that's the same as what their
policy preferences are in fact usually
the two are unrelated and people will
vote for a party
and have very little knowledge of what
the policy like preferences of the
parties they're supporting are
yeah the policy specific thing is is
good because i know that even here in
canada
i like a i don't usually know half of
the platforms that
for the politicians i'm voting for and b
most of them aren't even [ __ ] clear
about what they're gonna do when they
get into office until they just
do the napoleon thing and they just dive
in and then think from there
right they no nobody like maybe our
green party or our ndp will put on like
a fully worked out platform that you can
go through and look at each thing
individually but our main parties the
libs and the conserves
they don't do [ __ ] they they put out
like some vague promises
half of which they don't follow
afterwards and it's the same thing yeah
for policy preference
it's it's silly there shouldn't be a
correlation and i'm glad to hear there
is barely one
yeah and it's just and it's just and
it's just people
you know so it's like yeah it's like
special interest money and then a bunch
of [ __ ] clueless citizens who have
incoherent views
who don't know anything in the middle
who are being hypnotized by the
spectacle of it all
and cultural concerns right i think
people are much more aware of like what
their cultural
membership and their identity membership
is that seems to be much more
important to people and that's really
self-imposed immaturity indeed
it's cultural polarization and
membership polarization but like
like you know economic and like policy
preference like people are [ __ ]
clueless about that [ __ ] like they don't
know
i'll give you a sexy uh spectacle
quotation from deboer
politics will eventually be replaced by
imagery he writes this in what the
60s or whenever this was written the
politician will be too happy to abdicate
in favor of his image
or we could include party because the
image
slash party will be much more powerful
than he could ever be
it's working it's doing what it should
i just wanted to say there's a really
funny thing there's a comment i want to
make about the economic issue
and then i also want to make a simpsons
reference um actually i'll go with the
simpsons reference first because
what i always use to explain this to my
students uh when talking about the
incoherence of people's views is
you might remember there was that
episode where um
the stu the teachers go on strike
because they're not getting paid enough
and they all meet in front of the
parents and cabral gives this big long
speech she's like
don't you want to give your children a
good education all the parents are like
yeah yeah children are the future and
skinner goes up he's like
yeah but to do it we'd have to raise
taxes and then all the parents were like
oh the taxes we can't put up with that
and then she's like come on and they're
like oh yeah kids the future future
and he like like does that little motion
with his hand about money and they're
like oh yeah that hand thing means the
taxes and stuff right
this is really how it is that voters
actually tend to approach a lot of
issues if you
offer them the option of supporting
left-wing programs without attaching it
to any kind of cost
they'll usually say yes right because
who doesn't want
more public services right for the most
part
yeah if you don't attach to any cost and
also if you don't attach any like
cultural meaning to it right so so if
you if you just ask them something
really specific
without saying whether it's like left
wing or whatever like
yeah exactly you can get like a really
conservative person and be like yeah
like i want that
like i want and then but if you're like
oh it's like socialized medicine then
they're like no i don't care exactly you
can even use vague rhetoric right do you
think
the government should be more
compassionate towards those who need it
right and
a lot of people will think like well i
believe in compassion so yes check check
and all of a sudden you sound like a dsa
or right
but like on the economic point i mean
this is one of the things that i
actually think
attests uh to what you see with trumpism
which is important
uh because there have been a number of
different studies done in political
psychology to assess whether marx was
actually right
and people feel a sense of class
consciousness and it turned out that the
best empirical evidence we have right
now is that he was half right
unlike what a lot of neoliberal
economists claimed
people don't just make evaluations about
how well they're doing
by comparing themselves to themselves
right i don't just ask myself
am i doing better today than i was
yesterday which was kind of the thatcher
question in the 1980s right i will
actually ask
how am i doing relative to other people
right
the problem is that we don't tend to ask
how is the working class doing relative
to the capitalist class
or how is joe the plumber doing next to
jeff bezos i guess elon musk will be the
new poster boy for
just incomparable graft i asked myself
how am i joe the plumber doing next to
professor so-and-so who's toilet eye
repair right
we make interpersonal comparisons the
person who's above us immediately
right and this is extremely problematic
since it means it's
very difficult to actually mobilize
people against ruling elites because the
elites can say
well though the people that you are
angry at aren't us
you shouldn't be pissed off at you know
the capitalist class
you should be angry at the doctors the
lawyers the educators the bureaucrats
all these undeserving people who think
they're better than you uh who live in a
nicer neighborhood than you and who are
able to send their kids to cool colleges
uh when you have to settle for a
community college or state level college
or whatever it happens to be right
and it's really effective because those
are the people that we tend to compare
ourselves to
mentally right and i think that there's
a lot of common sense to
back this up right i don't typically sit
there thinking to myself
geez you know i wonder i'm so pissed off
uh that that judge on the supreme court
is making 250
000 i should be making that i sit there
and i think i should have a tenured
position or
that phd student who got a scholarship
his work isn't much better than mine i
should have a scholarship
all that kind of stuff yeah i mean i i
agree i was just gonna i was thinking
about how
this this human tendency to compare
ourselves uh to others i'm just noticing
a lot a lot of like
the right-wing reaction to what happened
at the capitol right is is immediately
doing what we call what about ism but i
think it like speaks to a similar thing
which is just like comparing it's like
okay like my people did this but like
what about antifa and
and blm and stuff and it's always
thinking about like what is
what is being culturally legitimized um
on my team and what is being culturally
condemned on the other team and what's
the what's the balance and what's the
material difference i mean i'm seeing
that talking point all over
all over right-wing i think it's a
problem because it pisses and that
pisses me off because i'm like look
you might be able to condemn some of the
violence that was committed uh
during the protest during the summer but
there's no doubt that they were
motivated by something that's a genuine
concern
right which is the murder of an innocent
person uh by a police officer
right uh whereas this was motivated by a
desire to overturn a democratic election
to make sure that their own guy would
get in office so
that's you can be more sympathetic than
that i'm not
i'm actually less sympathetic than i'm
betraying myself here well deep state
pedophiles are trying to kick
out your guy and put in put in a
zombie animated corpse guy who
represents the establishment and has his
entire life
if that were the if those were the
stakes i'd probably get a cow hat on too
yeah that's true i mean whenever you
think about the reality of what happened
that picture that
image of all those dudes and inside of
the capitol and that guy with the horn
the q anon dude
is gonna be in one of those like hundred
years of photography books right next to
the
right next to the carpet bombing
pictures and the moon landing pictures
and
that's going to be in there and now q
anon is going to be
like just fixed in the
american historical memory for the next
century
because of that [ __ ] it's pretty
barbarian from diablo ii come to life
yeah yeah we flip yeah we flip it
through your [ __ ] history book and
they'll be like
the two towers falling down they'll be
like bush with like the mission
accomplished thing and then there'll be
that dude
with the horns and the q sent me the the
professional blm counter protesters
honestly i'm very
most mostly jealous of q anon with
the fact that they've just been able to
develop and nurture and have so much
buy-in to an entire cosmology of the
world that is completely
divorced from reality i mean we can
thank facebook for it in part
is eric and i as eric and i discussed on
a
patreon podcast yesterday yeah it's the
condition of their possibility
but i'm jealous where is where are our
myth makers
that's the thing the news that's like
this was walter benjamin's point in the
storyteller with our hyper-connected
world what i was saying earlier
instant explanation right nothing has
time to become a story
nothing has time to be mythologized it's
all explained
immediately and that takes away that you
lose something
in your culture maybe maybe it's this is
a bit of an older view now but you do
lose something
when you can't tell stories like i said
we'd all be hearing about this
as it comes through the proper media
channels and is filtered in various ways
but we get sort of raw unfiltered
imagery
and in a way that's like more confusing
and even worse
than at least we have professional news
people
organizing it for us and putting
together the narratives for us
and in the meantime we can sort of
mythologize and speculate
and then when we get the full story
those things come together
and it creates something bigger but
today we just get whatever your
whatever your echo chamber wants to say
whether whether it's
and most of those time those echo
chambers are filled with with twitter
robots and
what do you call that [ __ ] copy pasta
where someone immediately just makes all
these posts about things like i think i
think i'm seeing one now about
about the blm protests because people
will make the points
people will make all these points
someone will anticipate it and make a
copy pasta
and then it goes through the echo
chambers and everyone just copy paste
copy paste and that's that's
arguments today is what about ism and
copy pasta
that's that's what our online discourse
is at right now
it's a very it's a very good it's
straight out of ivy league level of of
debate there
we are being turned into algorithmic
subjects i just want to finish this up
because this is actually about
humanon it was really funny because i
was looking into a little bit about
how he sends them messages and i was
kind of thinking to myself that in some
ways this is really appealing because
many of us sometimes feel a sense of
existential dread at like the
meaninglessness of existence but these q
and on people
really have an almost like excessively
meaningful world
and the problem the preeminent example
of this is there was this picture of
trump with a bunch of other
senior republicans and they were all
giving a thumbs up to something
and one of the symbols that these people
interpreted as being from human on was
the fact that if you draw a circle
around their thumbs
and draw a line between one thumb and
another it looks like a giant
cue and this was taken to be a sign that
all these republicans are into it
and they're sending a message to their
supporters that they're all part of the
conspiracy right
it's fitting that he wears them that
that bull headdress because it's a
completely totemic religion
he probably drinks loads of nyquil too
all the time giant [ __ ] cue there too
yeah can i just make a point about um
the the protest so i think what one
point i was thinking about yesterday is
i think on a previous podcast we talked
about um you know the
like use of violence or rioting the
legitimacy of rioting and i
and i think i might have said at the
time you know that i have less of a
problem
with people destroying government
property uh versus people's private
property right like like just destroying
some random person's like you know small
business or something
so like to some extent i think like
yesterday it's like if you're gonna riot
or something you know
even though i totally obviously
disagreed with the message it's like
the fact that they're rioting and like a
symbol of the or
you know that's a government institution
it's it's like that's that seems like a
more legitimate target to me
yeah they did a good job people yeah
we're going to be we're talking about it
it's symbolic and it's and it's it's you
know it's
it's public property they didn't kill
anybody well yeah they didn't kill
anybody themselves right like so i would
be like i'm i would say i'm more
supportive
of of destruction of property when it's
public property first i will also say
that there was kind of an amusing
element to this where
apparently ted cruz and a couple of the
other like mega far right trumpists
were amongst the first people to
evacuate and i read an article where it
was like
it's kind of amusing that they weren't
willing to sit there and just deal with
the monster that they created
or helped create as it like stormed into
their [ __ ]
headquarters and all of its glory
and [ __ ] i can just imagine ted cruz
with his ivy league education looking at
the guy with the [ __ ]
news helmet being like that's your man
teddy
i'm your number one fan yeah it's
interesting that
we don't we we never took seriously all
the all the incitement
when it was just in words but now that
it's cropped up in in images of video
and now we're all like stunned that it
really happened
it's so we we still kind of culturally
draw a really hard line between words
and images
words words can be uh deceptive and and
kind of meaningless but for some reason
images are
are traumatic and shocking and and and
somehow that's where we draw the line
now we're all outraged we're not
outraged by the
uh telling of people the incitement of a
riot we're
enraged when the riot actually happens
that's
it's self-defeating it's funny it's
funny you say that because i think are
you i'm assuming you're thinking about
like these politicians who are now all
of a sudden like outraged by what
happens even though they've been like
letting this incitement happen
the outrage i think the reason for that
is because paul
and i mean i think politicians are are
often thinking
very narrow-mindedly about um their own
like interests to be re-elected so like
they are making very very situational
calculations
about what they should how they should
react to something and they're thinking
about voters
so i think like oftentimes they let
these things slide and weren't thinking
about like the broader
implications of what they were sort of
like morally legitimizing or authorizing
um and more just thinking well i really
don't want to piss off this base this
base is really energized i need to
make sure that i'm in their good books i
need to make sure that you know i don't
they don't like turn on me uh you know
it's very narrow calculator like
cruz was making these i don't know like
half gestures
sort of like endorsing or stoking before
all this happened
canadian by the way we're we're not
sending our best
at all um i feel like you made that joke
before on this podcast i think i made it
with respect to that
lauren southern is she canadian yeah she
is i made it
with respect to her so we still haven't
actually actually actually finished bbc
so congratulations
we have a few more awful people to go
through that we've sent down there but
at least
we get rid of them but anyway they hate
they hate and will never
love cruz because they can smell that on
him they can smell this uh
uh political maneuvering on him in a way
that trump
is too too narcissistic and too filled
with his own
ego or his own lack of ego that he's
trying to feel genuine
so then they they're never going to love
him and this is kind of why
my theory of this is that it's a pseudo
event is that there's nobody
with that gravitas that that desire that
trump has
that could fill that place like even
when don jr does it
tries to incite the the yokels he's
totally
um transparently try hard
about it and the thing that trump
doesn't have is the ability to look like
he's trying hard because it's his
it embodies his entire being to sort of
act this is
so true so who comes who can keep trump
going or who can keep trumpism going
who can keep the the bullhead guy go
going
after this after he's gone and unless he
starts doing it from the sidelines and
goes to a media outlet but there's no
one yeah i'm i'm wondering
i think i think i think the most likely
candidate for that is
somebody from like cable news so yeah
tucker carlson
or like or like one of these people who
is already part of like the
you know the the hyper reel like
whatever these you know baudrillardian
terms you like to use
like part of that like ecosystem that's
going to have like
i agree with you it can't be one of
these conventional politicians
no matter how much they supported trump
they just don't embody
the rhetoric but you know hannity is
sean hannity uh uh you know tucker
carlson one of these people i could
imagine them
coming in and being scarier because that
they're at least tucker carlson i think
i'm gonna actually make a prophecy right
here and i want you guys to note it
because when i'm proven right in 10
years we're going to look back on this
and
i'm going to just masturbate uh with
players
you know a self-confident person another
prediction i i predicted there was going
to be another
oklahoma first they went for a movie
star with reagan
then they went reality tv star with
trump the only place to go is porn star
next
so i think that's ultimately what we're
going to see
it's a hot prediction i like it i'm
gonna i'm gonna say
it's gonna be kanye trying to win back
kim he's gonna do this grand romantic
gesture he's gonna run for president and
be like this one's for you
take me back please and he's gonna try
and do it to impress her he could have
crossed the aisle support
yeah or it could be or it could be a
youtuber
oh god to me to be actually a youtuber
frightening or president pewdiepie you
two could be a youtuber
yeah yeah it could be like it could be
one or it could be one of those would
have to die before that
he's not american though no but one of
these like american right wing like
youtube commentators honestly like
you know in all to like in response to
you know matt you're joking about a porn
star but i feel like equally absurd but
probably much more likely one of these
[ __ ] weird right-wing youtubers has a
shot
could you even imagine like a [ __ ]
president dave rubin what would that be
like
i mean god you thought that donald you
thought donald trump was [ __ ] dumb
you'd sit there and bli dave would be
like whoa what city i am again
you're in the white house don't worry
about it
oh okay good what yeah
yeah uh it would be [ __ ] up these
[ __ ] grifters man i swear
i don't know i don't know it would have
to be somebody who's that's the thing
though like
the the problem is that there's the a
lot of these people are grifters it
would have to be one who really believes
like the way that trump believes
you know i stand by my porn star
prediction though i think that there's a
teleology to history here
and the natural evolution of the moral
majority types is that eventually
they're going to sell their soul so hard
that they're going to bring in somebody
who used to get banged hard
i don't mean to run for president i
don't mean to be the old dead horse but
i think we're all going to come together
when the real
impacts of climate change and 50 years
start to come there
that's going to be the external enemy
finally unites us
all and of course it'll be far too late
by then but we're all going to be
[ __ ] saints
in 50 60 years we're all gonna be saints
you don't think it's gonna you don't
think it's just gonna lead to it's gonna
lead to what's it called like um
like a like an apocalypse no not it'll
be like a 911
fact except like over many many years as
everyone's just gonna come together
against the external enemy except the
external enemy is going to be
well ourselves but also the hundred
industries that have done this to the
world
and various other things
or we'll end up like mad max no it won't
be well it'll be mad max
afterwards but leading up to them like
when after it's too late but we're all
trying to stop it that's when we're all
that's going to be the best time
because we're all going to come together
the political binaries will be abolished
because we'll all be green party
and then but it'll be too late of course
by then barring some amazing technology
being invented that can scrub
loads of carbon out of the atmosphere uh
they are politicized
a virus though dude i don't have much
hope fooded
the republicans that is true
maybe not the republic the cues but the
virus is doing the exact opposite
with the virus we're all stuck where we
are
with climate change we're going to see
millions and millions of refugees
pouring in
from on the coasts and from all over the
place
and it's gonna be a very different
problem i mean at first it's gonna be
rough
because we have seen the refugee crisis
uh that's like on the back burner now
apparently we haven't heard much about
that but once that starts back up again
we're gonna be going through some [ __ ]
and then finally we're all going to come
together because nobody's denying
climate change anymore it's not this
isn't the 2010s
for [ __ ] sake nobody's denying climate
change anymore
so we're all going to come together over
it today we can argue about what caused
what i hope so did that whose fault is
this but
we can argue about jerk off about the
cultural war and like you know
transgender bathrooms and nonsense
well while we're while we're making
predictions i predict that q
becomes a fully-fledged state religion
in the in the conservative ethno state
in what is now centered in what is now
florida the q party um which
which at the same time goes underwater
and then
there is a great war between the
northern
united states and the q state do you
think there's a chance that there could
be a third party like emerge in the
states
in reaction to this like a mega party or
something that's going to totally split
the conservative vote i mean i hope so
that'd be good for the democrats
strategically there's just no reason it
seems
it is possible i i am genuinely i
thought today that
what might very well happen is that the
republicans might try to find some way
to actually just
outright exclude trump from being able
to run for office because he's made a
lot of political enemies well that's
that's actually if that actually happens
well that's actually why i think
i think there's a chance that that they
could impeach trump after he leaves
office right because if they impeach him
after he leaves
that means he can't legally be president
again
oh yeah but it won't keep him from
campaigning to be corrupt president even
if that's the law
right uh yeah but that's what you're
right i think that's why the republicans
might actually support impeachment
because they might just not want to let
trump be president again
yeah exactly but in that case it would
shock me if he didn't decide to create
if not a party at least some kind of
movement that centered around himself
well exactly that's why i'm thinking
maybe there'd be a chance for for a mega
party or something or like yeah a cue
party or something crazy
yeah i mean that'd be that'd be fun that
could they could just finally get rid of
like even the vestige of respectability
just have dancing girls appear when like
[ __ ] trump is like up going up on
office
[ __ ] like just tank drive-through oh
my god
i needed some catharsis after yesterday
and so i watched the movie idiocracy
oh yeah that's always a good one ugh i
wish it wasn't uh
a prospect or prophetic film
yeah yeah that one's prophetic as [ __ ]
yeah matt stone trey parker were
geniuses of a certain sword oh that
wasn't
that was uh mike judge actually oh
sorry [ __ ] yeah no i was thinking
basketball yeah that was the one
my bad [ __ ] anyway i feel i feel
cathartised which is
sort of the purpose of participating in
the spectacle in the way we do we've
we've had our small headbutts catharsis
reviewed the events of the day yeah god
as a political junkie it was [ __ ]
impossible for me to get any work done
yesterday like i was trying and i was
just obsessively watching the news
like it's i know i was getting messages
from all kinds of people being like
you've seen the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
going on look at this
isn't it [ __ ] up and i was like yeah
eric and i recorded
an episode on cybernetics that had
absolutely i guess we
brought it in [ __ ] a little bit
i tried to stay off twitter yeah well
what's the lesson here i think we should
can we should start holding politicians
a little more accountable for the [ __ ]
they say
but also make sure that we hold them
accountable
for evasive and non-answery kind of
[ __ ] that
was kind of the standard in the past and
now now it's kind of just you can say
anything and it doesn't matter because
it's trump
and you can pre-record a video and
pretend that you're in canada when
you're in cancun
yeah exactly those are the real
disgusting people i agree
non-answers not cool and incitement to
riot
also not cool should be automatic
punishment for that but
i think the solution has been staring us
in the face for a very long time
we just need justin trudeau to invade
the united states
annex the northern parts of it create an
eco-socialist paradise
with himself as permanent leader and
then
at least take care of north america we
could even
get mexico on board i mean amlo's there
right now
and just create kind of like a united
north american federation that only
excludes the americans
we could give them alberta too if they
want it yeah they can take it yeah okay
sure yeah they can slice them yeah they
can build a castle
from alberta who are listening yeah no
no i'm just saying i was just thinking
about how that would kind of be
difficult
that would be a wrench in our plan of
creating an ego socialist
utopia i feel like the albertans
wouldn't be particularly excited about
that
yeah i mean we can just create like it'd
be almost like a state in the state
because we'll carve off like the coast
down through georgia into florida do
like a little exemption down there
and then they can just have like the
midwest from like louisiana texas up
there
like a big giant kidney and then we can
we can all get it it'll be a paradise
save in the world one
fair trade organic bean starbucks coffee
at a time
well it's kind of funny you say that
though because a lot of like the
post-liberal
like theory um right now they do often
talk about
um the need for more um
pluralism of or more localism right more
more insular cultures bottom up and they
and i did notice like after after like
the democrats won
uh the senate they were like i saw a lot
of discussion
of you know maybe we need to secede you
know secession
stuff and like maybe maybe if that
things keep going that way it could be a
real
a real deal the albertan separatists
said the same thing when uh trudeau won
it's like all right yeah we're gonna get
out of here we have no access to
we're an oil economy with no access to a
port but we're just gonna
leave by yeah that was more funny for
exactly that reason i remember
they mclean's interview with the head of
the alberta separatist party and brought
that exact thing up and they were like
well i'm not sure it'll be a problem you
know we'll find a way to negotiate and
get a better deal than we have right now
and they're like what better deal could
you have than being part of the country
where you're trying to get you know move
your oil to the coast and it's like
well we'll sort that out afterwards it's
like i don't know i really think you
should have a solution to that now since
this is really
the whole reason you want separatism
yeah that's a little brexity a little
bit of a brexit like oversight there
yeah i agree with the more communal i
don't know about insular but definitely
communal
you know facebook face down bottom up
that's the way i like my politics to be
conducted
all right listeners we hope that you
have taken this train of uh
intensified emotion and then catharsis
and now we are all chill now we don't
need we can continue to do
whatever it is we've been doing mostly
nothing um so
thank you all for being a part of our uh
climax
and then you know the the cigarette the
cigarette after
yeah the dainum yeah why don't we just
sign off from the pill pod this is
pills matt eric victor and uh
what am i saying man thank you
thank you bear with us